[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
directing traffic lebron james
[Applause]
brockton backing up picked by carmelo
he'll back it up now with seven on the
shot clock
lebron about to get into his action
launches a three got it the king
the king from distance he's got to play
some defense here they're in his tag
zone
at the other end gets fouled
so they did what they needed to do
take it right out of the net and do
something quickly clock stops with a
minute nine but a huge shot by lebron
lebron just steps back and turner has no
chance of getting to it and the three
long distance the shot clock was
becoming an issue in lebron
lebron with an opportunity to possibly
get him out of the game instead he gets
look at the clock with two the brought
again for three
he hits another from downtown
speculation and couldn't hold on
to another three-point attempt well here
he is with five with four lebron steps
for another three got another one
lebron drains another one
yes sir
i've been letting the pacer fans know it
they've been on him a little bit tonight
and his play has been on them as he puts
the lakers up by six but still
a minute and 52 left to play don't get
real excited until
it's over as lebron steps back
let's fly look at that thing splash
nothing
but
bottom
that is just nice
[Music]
it's a bonus i'm saying coach what do
you expect me to do
that's lebron james the king in the
clutch
wow
i mean wow
[Applause]
this is fun
give it to lbj short clock again three
with two lebron fall away yes
lebron